A common answer we heard from our students, is that the word delegate,
makes them think of the relationship between a boss and an employee.
Perhaps you've been in a situation where your boss has delegated some work to
you, or given you some work.
The idea of delegating work is similar in iOS,
here you can think of AV audio recorder like boss.
It knows how to record audio.
It also knows when the recording is done and is ready for playback.
In fact, if you look deep enough in the code for AV audio recorder you'll find
a function called audio recorder did finish recording.
This is the function that gets called when the recording has finished.
Now honestly, this seems like a method we could use in our class.
Record sounds view controller.
Remember the situation where our user would record a five minute long
conversation with a friend on their app?
If somehow we had access to this method,
it could tell us exactly when the audio was recorded successfully, so
then we could do things with that audio, for instance, playback.
So then, why doesn't av audio recorder just tell our class that hey.
Audio has been recorded successfully.
Well, one reason for that is that we wrote our class today.
And this class, AVAudioRecorder, was written by an Apple engineer years ago.
At the time they wrote this class,
they had no idea we would be writing our class.
And that we would call it record sounds view controller.
One way Apple decided to overcome this problem,
was by delegating the implementation of methods like this, to classes like ours.
Our class record sounds view controller can take advantage of this method,
if we become a delegate of AV audio recorder.
So to make this boss, employee, or
delegate relationship work in our code, we have to do two things.
The first thing we have to do, is to change the definition of record sounds view
controller by adding this thing av audio recorder delegate to it.
The second thing we have to do is, somewhere in our class,
we have to write this line of code: audio recorder dot delegate equal to self.
Self here means record sounds view controller.
And what this statement is saying is that RecordSoundsViewController is now
the delegate of audioRecorder.
After we have done these two things, we can then implement the function
audioRecorderDidFinishRecording inside our class.
So in the next video, we will add these two things to our code.